[Musik]
hast du noch nie schwarze brauche ich
mir jetzt noch mal dass sogar das
voluminöse murat glas und ich habe das
mal einem tee getrunken
das kann doch jetzt nicht sein und ich
weiß jetzt geld oder ich mache mir her
du hast noch nie ich bis jetzt nicht
wahr nicht getrunken habe ich kann mich
erinnern
dieses geld ist ringsheim folgen was
trinkt man dann irgendwann ist doch
schon mal was teilweise schöne bei
bestimmten handy krank deswegen habe ich
manche sehen das wird bei uns von
morgens bis abends mit schwarzlicht denn
geschmeckt anders als michaels gut
geschmeckt
was ist ein wunderbar etwas getrunken
das ist der super lecker also
unglaublich dieser tee ist was macht
oder prost oder gut
ich wusste aber dass wir laufen 12 3
series hallo herzlich willkommen so
verlief bis heute stehe ich nicht allein
in der küche ich habe heute starke
partner hinter hier zum einen calvin
hollywood anderen patric heizmann who
und wieso kam es hier zu dem treffen der
calvin ist leidenschaftlicher käsekuchen
es sieht man sich aber nicht an das auch
das einzige was ich gut kann case kuchen
essen und also für mich ist es so
stellen sich auf eine bühne vor 4000
menschen kinderspiel
aber jetzt hier zu stehen um zu packen
das ist was anderes ist schon hin ich
war ja grundschulleiterin und ich sage
immer wenn es kindern erklären kann
wenn kinder verstehe ich bin dein herz
legen oder mehr sorgen du verstehst auch
kann ein reservierter rausschmeißt war
sexistisch
das irgendwann irgendwo irgendwie
stadion gezeigt werden kann ein hat den
regisseur bitte aus dem studio verweis
rauschen köpft drüber sagen nein
also wir uns jetzt gedacht ich mein
erster der beiden du bist auch du auch
nichts wert auf gesunde ernährung auf
bewegung auf sport du auch auf gutes ja
auch bei dirk mit der ernährung du
machst dann viel sports maus gehört ich
muss mal dann wieder ausgleichen wir
sind ja ein jahr spielen müssen ich bin
bekannt für leckeres essen und dann
haben wir's jetzt gedacht heute machen
wir einen leckeren käse kuchen mit
mandarinen zu hatten sich gewünscht aber
damit wir auch alle einen mehrwert davon
haben denke ich sollten wir auch einen
käsekuchen mit dir machen und der
vielleicht etwas gesünder ist genau das
möchte ich ein bisschen geschmacks
homöopathischer auf kunst ingredienzien
aber ist auf jeden fall lohnt auch nicht
unter heißt horst 2.0 da gibt es nach
einer gar nicht okay also dann wäre ich
jetzt sagen starten mit dem kers kuchen
ich hoffe es ist okay wir machen einen
mit boden mit mickey und mit mandarinen
okay also hier stehen schon mal sich
zutaten für den mürbeteig nehmen wir 200
gramm kalte butter 80 gramm puderzucker
eine prise salz 300 gramm dinkelmehl ein
eigelb und etwas mangel extrakt und für
die käsekuchen füllung auch etwas man
den extrakt 200 gramm zucker 125 gramm
weiche butter vier eier und ein eiweiß
eine zitrone 200 gramm sahne 500 gramm
quark 200 gramm creme fraiche 40 gramm
stärke und eine dose mandarinen dies gut
hier
die ist gut ja erkennt dass die hat
doppeln trieb mir ziemlich große aber
ich habe es mir vorstelle meinte dass
planetarische rohrsystems das heißt wenn
man sich verwirrt hat kann es wieder
zurück grünen links rum deshalb weiß ich
bin bei dem bohrer da gibt es rechts und
links rum oder wie beim auto starb ist
noch warm war es am markt
das muss ich euch die maschine erklären
das ist über dem die maschine über die
du sprichst steht hinter dir was die
große kitchenaid sieht auch gut aus
ja die kann auch wenn man die haben
brauchen wir keine frauen so wie sonst
nur sechs ich die dinge recht doch gar
nicht wenn wir so ein ding zu hause hat
braucht man keine frau merkel hätte sich
ständig rassistischer und damit raus
haben recht es sagte man hätte er vor
mir die kennen und gab theatermenschen
mich nicht heiraten müssen ja es stimmt
auch nur haben sich öffentlich sagen wir
stecken unterschieden hier keiner ernst
werde also ich schon jetzt aber alles
beim alten
jetzt weiß ich warum die videos 60
minuten alles drehen oder vielleicht
schon ist der weiblichkeit kennen wird
weiter um endlich oder ist also immer
okay okay also wären also ich glaube
calvin das mit seinem ersten tag in
deinem leben
es wird generell mein erstes mal hier
deswegen muss schön werden wie zum
beispiel das ist ja dann nehme ich jetzt
hier kalte butter in komplett ohne glas
so viel entschuldigung hat der kurs hat
noch was los ist sehr ungesund oder ja
und zwar kann man sich bei mürbeteig
merken dass ich so ein 123 kein teil
zucker zwei teile getrennt alles mit
geschmack ist ja den beträgen geschmack
vermögensmasse der metrik ist er eher so
fein und kurz und das matschige creme
kommt er hier war man also kalte butter
zucker und salz allez allez
das tut ihr das ist dem herrn ein mehr
an und sticht das tut nicht weh weil
schon leckere kuchen lecker schmecken
und lecker kommt über zucker und fett
vor allem die kombination gerne als
ganzes
jeder weiß dass jetzt mehr denken
hausstaub ist es nicht ja denke mir
nämlich da auch alles reine button ist
einfach wenn alles so vorbereitet ist
ist es recht einfach würde ich muss
zugeben ich habe auch selber noch nie in
vilbel
ich bin auch nicht der konsum einen
kleinen schluck vanille extrakt das ist
für einen geschmack genau statt vanille
zucker da sind echte vanille sahne
das ist natürlich schon videos sondern
halben teelöffel halben teelöffel von
dem ganzen zeug da was wir da immer so
ist eine fitness branche jetzt nimmst du
das handgerät man kann mit den händen
kneten aber der soll er nicht weich
werden also nicht warm durch die hände
sondern eher kalt bleiben
hast du links rum es so aber am besten
er streiche stecken und dann machen weil
sonst mit dem hamburger der guckt
grimmig und jetzt machen und hier kann
sich hier noch die fahrgeschwindigkeit
und jetzt und jetzt ja jetzt einfach so
eine persönliche wieder passieren es
gibt diese studie
ich gehe mal ein bisschen was ist jetzt
das ziel das ist schön sich vermischt
genau homogen wird die produkte aber
eine kleine herde hätte
becker zu hause ihr könnt einfach mixa
nehmen und einfach alles in so einem
mixer zerkleinern das geht schneller
aber ich wollte dass der sowieso
das wären das hat etwas meditatives ja
wie man macht man das so sagen jungs
macht eigentlich darin geht schneller
wenn es mir mixa gemacht hätte dann
hätten wir praktisch nichts mehr
nacharbeiten müssen aber jetzt nämlich
noch ein bisschen die hände
das sowieso nie betrachtet
jetzt kann es ein bisschen mit einer
hand wärme den teig so zusammenführen
müssen aber auch die sind waren aber was
muss jetzt machen wir selbst so weil die
meisten die kneten so mit den fingern
hat alles unter den nägeln das machen
wir nicht weg nähten er sohn hier
ok du drückst ihn eigentlich nur ein
ziel ist es das ist ein schock so also
nicht mit den fingern kneten sondern
eher mit dem handball bestimmt es also
jetzt 35 gemacht ich bin doch keine 35
bis 27.11 vor der kamera hier arabischer
zwei jahre jünger als ich weiß ich mache
jetzt genau das macht ihr gerade richtig
wirbel kann man diese mit wasser machen
das besser gelebt oder soll er nicht
geben
gesundes leben steht schon wir sind
schwaben also der rat zumindest wenn ich
mir vorstelle dass ich später ist mir wo
ich meine hände
das video ist kuchen jetzt für dich
finden die frage schon kritisch und ich
auch machen wir wieder mit ich ich kann
mir vorstellen das ist mal ein guter
käse wird
schnell ist es passiert deckel drauf und
in den kühlschrank und in der zeit
machen wir schon mal die füllung okay
das darfst du essen als belohnung ist
zucker und fett es kann gar nicht
schlecht schmecken zugeführt und vanille
extrakt ich versteh ich verstehe jetzt
aber nicht weil du jetzt gerade gesagt
hast die füllung kommt was wir jetzt
gerade gemacht haben ist der boden und
der rand also dreieck was ich später ist
das unten und es hinten ja und jetzt
kommt's ja schöne teil
und jetzt kommt der innere teil das
matschige manche mögen ja keine rand
maxi käsekuchen rand total hat mein
kuchen nicht aber ich mag es nicht gerne
weil ich mag dieses leichte durch meter
gemacht so knapp da gibt es diesen die
knack auf dem teller total gerne er
schon als kind ist brot die kruste weg
gelegt also von der mensch macht er den
matschigen teil sehr glücklich werden
weil das schmeckt so einem boden ist
gesund und das ist nicht automatisch
fleck aber dass sie überraschen
na ja ich bin echt gespannt drauf mein
schwager wollte schon immer mal dass ich
so ein gesundes fitness rezept mache
aber bis hast du noch nicht gemacht also
meine normalen kochrezepte völlig schon
relativ gut und ist als was ich sagen
darf meine frau hat gesagt so den gruß
an das holz mehr gesundes zeug machen
okay dass ich da mal drüber reden okay
also daher mürbeteig ist ein kühlschrank
der kühlgeräte und der kühl so etwa eine
halbe stunde habe ich denke die braucht
der kann auch für die füllung
wir haben jetzt hier weiche butter das
ist ganz wichtig und obama ja ich nehme
auch also du kannst hier die butter
nehmen
ich schütte noch allemal
ich brauche den löffel nicht weil alles
kommt eh alles rein so viel zucker 200
kommen das läuft doch alles du hast
gesagt ich soll und kuchen machen der
schmeckt
gar nicht sein da haben uns vertan ich
stets alles was du kannst die hessen
heute nicht so lecker nachher ist jetzt
ja ich werde später mal noch die
kalorien aus die ihm ein kuchen hat und
den kuchen und vergleichen
erst verrühren erst cremig für in butter
und zucker ich mache schon mal man den
extrakt dazu gemacht
gute taten überzeugung verabschiedet
ich bin ein sehr superreicher und
zerreiße wort hat habe ich bin ja ich
bin keine maschine keine transfettsäuren
weg und ich sage ganz ehrlich ich denke
mir immer ich es ja nicht jeden tag
süßes isst frühstück immer gesund und
ausgewogen ich habe zum mittag oder zum
abendessen immer etwas leckeres gesundes
und ich bin eher keine naschkatze als
ich nach auch beim backen mich und dann
denke ich mir so wenig schon mal ein
stück kuchen erst dann esse ich zeit
normal aber guck mal was
was mir zum beispiel auffällt wenn ich
so ein hungergefühl habe habe ich
meistens gar keinen hunger sondern durch
das heißt ich trink generell zu wenig
und guck mal ich hab jetzt schon wieder
der streichungen dot com wasser heute
getrunken aber ich merke dann so mir
fehlt was und erst dann neigt man dazu
zu sagen ich will jetzt kurz was essen
dabei müsste ich eher was trinken und
ich glaube das haben viele dass die das
verwechseln dieses hunger durst gefühl
genau also bring service gedacht wenn
wir jetzt den case krohn fertig haben
und denen vielleicht runde kriegen auf
drei bis viertausend kalorien dass man
offiziellen schießt einführen statt
entschied day und da können wir uns ja
den kunden schilder am tag verteilen
ja dafür wäre ich so jetzt müssen wir
nur auf die fährte und drei weltmeister
war bringen kannst du kannst den keks
kuchen backen in stücke schneiden nach
dem abkühlen und dann einfrieren und da
kann schon wirklich immer wenn du mal
lust auf ein kleines stück hast kann
doch die ein stück kuchen aufteilen
ich finde das klingt es ja ein musiker
ist auftauchen das heißt nicht ich hab
mich traurig essen ja in einem muss erst
auftauchen ja und da kam überlegen muss
ist jetzt das case studiert und sein
oder kann es auch mal ein schnitzel sein
also eine banane
einfach einen anderen natürlich auch
einmal ja sonst gewinnt die partie mit
streuseln oder ohne jedes wachsen wird
extrem sauer weil die so aufgestellt
dass wir so legte hosten oder sollten
wir durch einmalkosten max probieren ja
das muss man schon butter zucker kann
gerne probieren kleine löffel nur weil
es muss also auch kein problem ja auch
egal wo ich muss ja immer prüfen und
mich jetzt auf dem richtigen weg bin
wie soll schmecken mit 200 gramm zucker
trennten neben der zucker ist gesamt in
den zehn ich habe keinen strand wie ihre
markante sogar das noch ich glaube dass
der test noch mal wenn wir da jetzt
passiert sagen testen wenn alles drin
als atem sagt knirsch muss mich in den
museumsräumen ostfriese
zitronengeschmack ich muss meinen
geschmack vor reist und behauptet ohne
genau wie du wieder ne natur ernst und
ich mache noch besser zitronensaft
[Applaus]
aber guck mal da komme ich noch fast
jedes kind kennt sich auch auf die
konten der amazonas ist es besser so
etwas nicht zu wissen ja selbst immer
noch sarah genau jetzt das kommt jetzt
magerquark bei jedem training gesagt
wird mich werke und bisschen zitronen
sagt für die säure auch für den
geschmack die mandarine noch nicht die
würden jetzt darin sah matschie ist auch
gut für die haut ich hab jetzt klümpchen
okay und jetzt ganze probieren cook so
kann schon dann nämlich einfach
backformen ohne so schließen
wir kennen die kannte ich noch nicht die
zum hersteller der folie
ich danke für die kann 2000 mal benutzen
und dann dort sondern das ist die rache
nicht weitermachen
jetzt gehts grund gebaut also du kannst
es eine springform nehmen oder so ein
bug rahmen charakter gleichmäßiger und
du kannst später den namen einfach
hacken und jetzt nimmst du hier machst
so einer schlange also eine rolle und
damit vom so den rand also hier einfach
hochdrücken ja gut ist wird jetzt zu
lange dauern das video natürlich war das
einmal das heißt jetzt einmal gezeigt
und dann und das machst du jetzt ich hab
da mal was
also du kannst das ja hin drehen so
kleines turnier backform aus ok also
dieses wird das bett für die käse grund
füllung so 2 cm durchmesser
ich sage jetzt ist doch gar nichts an
dieser stelle mein stück an dieser
stelle sagt nächste kanzler und
verlieren nur spiele wohl stellt jetzt
und gleichmäßig bitte ist das spannende
daran ist dicker als die verlockt nicht
schlecht noch mal raus oder gedrückt
das stehe halt auf den dicken rand ja
ich auch also ich finde es nicht leicht
die teppich gehalten neben sandkasten
früheren soll ich machen
ja so ein bisserl versuchen gleich mit
ok machte einfach nicht wann ich war nie
im sandkasten gut dass jetzt du hast
schon mit vier fotografien gelernt
sozusagen also an kassen fotografiert
ich will hier dünnen rand haben also
mache schon jetzt auch dünner da muss
man nichts retten
ich habe eine andere strategie nicht
wieder froh dass ich das nicht versuchen
muss wahrscheinlich auch hier kläglich
versagt ja ja wir mal möchte ich dir
einfach mal ganz kurz sollte man noch
mal probieren weil es jetzt noch eine
weile gestanden wir müssen immer wieder
an
20 männer händeabdruck weil das auch
eine weile gestanden
da muss man immer wieder mal
zwischendurch probieren ob da nicht
[Musik]
so genießen
peter 500 kalorien jeder läufer skater
hockey park für den boden nicht so ein
bisschen übrig aber gut das kann man
hier noch mal da unten schon raus wie du
das machst du machst es super aber jetzt
schon jetzt wieder mit den kindern gibt
es keine große ohren pudding also das
was wir jetzt so ein zirkus schon bis
jetzt ist muss doch geben ja wer schon
lecker also gibt's nicht demnächst
installiert
ich stehe als bisher sondern sondern
löffel des herrn ich finde es jetzt das
ist eine löffeln genau vielleicht ohne
eier ohne ruhe
ja wenn man länger steht in köln das
bedenklich werden das sieht alles sehr
gut aus aber es solche dicken stellen
solltet ihr vielleicht vermeiden
das heißt die können wir dann im
empfinger hier so am rand runter drücken
sondern habt ihr dort nicht zu dicke
tankstelle später weiß omv am rand wir
wollen ja er hier so den rechten winkel
jetzt da nicht zu dick dann einfach den
rest gegen die mitte ich glaube da geht
richtig gut
der wirt phänomenal ich habe einen ich
habe einfach gebacken weil ich nicht
genau wusste wie calvin fakt ist dass
ich raus bin
du hast eine villa das team gebraucht
viertelstunde auf geht deswegen jetzt
auch plus die floskel seite die hälfte
und jetzt darfst du bei deinen
mandarinen 16 schöne richtig schöne
mandarinen hier einsortieren
denn die schönen wollen wir
ich frage mich gerade das schöne
mandarine
sie sehen alle gleich aus lass dich
inspirieren
yahoo mal die ist nicht schön was was
war das schön
die kommt dann rein und ihm die
unschönen kann man gleich essen gegangen
hier rein du willst ja viele mandarin
oder na ja dass viele aber dies ist
nicht gut
allerdings macht monitor dann probieren
endlich wird aber die war gut ist kommen
abrechnen sie sehen alle irgendwie also
ich finde die sind alle irgendwie nicht
so schön dies auch niemals bis zu ende
packen muss ständig probieren
wahrscheinlich wäre ein kuchen später
nur noch halb so stark aus wie die jetzt
so was machen wir jetzt die mandarin
hier rein
die idee die nicht so schön wir
verstecken wir jetzt unter der creme
aber nicht einschritten denn diese
flüssigkeit also wo ich mit der hand
eine saubere hände und einfach so genau
so ein stein werfen richtigen ausgewählt
dass so was also wenn ihr keine man ring
mit lass das weg oder wieder patrick
schon gesagt hat heidelbeeren himbeeren
was ihr mir gehören was gibt es noch für
birnen dass in jedem live video immer
wenn ich dann sagt es kommen immer
anderen sagt er mit mandarinen viele
mandarinen und jetzt haben wir machen
das schon für viele damals schon ein
paar so ich habe schon die botschaft
verstanden und jetzt darfst du die
kühlung hier einzeln die käsekuchen
löffel machst du mal probieren oder ich
glaube dass es dort aber einfach einen
schützen genau also ich will ihn in die
mitte oder muss ich jetzt so eine frau
in die form über den genau so verteilen
reflexe reflex in seinem element
ja das hat schon die hälfte gegessen den
hab ich gemacht hier nicht über die
backformen und dann kann stehend aber
neben aber kein case gut was brauche ich
jetzt was wenn das öl war das grab
vorsicht denn da hat er weiter kevin ich
zeige dir das noch mal richtig
hier wird wie spielerisch ist noch ein
ganzes stück case gucken ja so hätte das
gestarteten 10.000 kalorien los neuen
hallen ja ja jetzt ist etwas noch mit
dabei hatte bestimmt mehr gespurt
wir machen wie du wirst mal andersrum
und die mandarinen die sind nicht nur
für den geschmack da sondern sie sorgen
auch dafür dass die oberfläche von
käsekuchen nicht reist kann man es miley
machen oder so warum reißen einfach
diese oberflächenspannung dann gebrochen
wird ansonsten wir so ein krater drin
genau ansonsten reichs käsekuchen immer
gerne ist dass wegen dem entgegen
das habe ich gerade frei erfunden aber
ich glaube die begründung stimmt ich
konnte zu habe ich war so fokussiert ja
weil der reise immer wegen der
oberflächenspannung auch so ist doch
zumindest er kommt jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad hitze
unter einschob leiste für 75 minuten
dann schalten wir ihn aus dann noch zehn
minuten darin abkühlen lassen
herausnehmen und komplett abkühlen
lassen und in der zeit haben wir einen
käsekuchen schon zehn mal gebacken
ready for take off
also haben wir die zutaten du stellst
sie kurz vor wir haben einmal
eiweißpulver mit meinen geschmack dann
haben wir bei wunderbarem erster zum
einfach mehr eiweißgehalt eben das
produkt reinzubekommen
wir haben 500 gramm quark das sind
übrigens jeweils 25 gramm
wir haben hier ist das werden viele
kenntnisse eine mischung aus joghurt und
quark dann haben wir hier den ganz
normalen frischkäse und zwar nicht die
fed reduzierte variante wir haben hier
ein käsekuchen pulver das schmeckt dann
wie case kuchen auf insulin basis das
ist was wunderbares sogar für den darm
wir haben vier ganze eier und wir haben
hier flohsamenschalen das ist ungefähr
vier teelöffel okay also dass
eiweißpulver das eine ist mit vanille
genauer schmecken ja dann aber hier
antrat ist ein bug ein weiß man einfach
mehr zu ersetzen also normalerweise
nicht kompletter sitzen also 50 50 egal
welchen rezepten immer verwenden also
auch bei der asse kuchen würde das geben
und das ist praktisch das schon
backbetrieb mittel so katrin ok
milchprotein konnte also auf milchbasis
ja okay okay also im prinzip getrocknete
getrocknet das milcheiweiß prüfer
richtig eben mit diesem bug drittmittel
lange da also das was eben normalerweise
backpulver mit ronja und so bekommt man
sozusagen die proteine in den kuchen ja
und ok genau und das tolle ist protein
eiweiß ist genau das gleiche verdikt
lange jetzt habe ich aber eine frage
also mir hat mal einer gesagt wenn man
viel sport macht sondern diese protein
shakes trinken muss kann man aber mir
wurde gesagt wenn du die trinkst und
dann nicht zum sport gehst gehst du auch
wie ein hefeteig
du solltest dir von diesem menschen
bitte keine ernährungstipps mehr und ok
gleichzeitig sage also ich kann diese
protein shakes auch als ich würde sagen
wenn du ganz normal ist und da merken
doch ein protein shake trinke wird ist
dann könnte das passieren weil das sind
letztendlich auch kalorien sind wenig
kalorien zu den schenk hat etwas mehr
als 100 kalorien das ist nicht okay aber
auf dauer gesehen
kalorien mehr kalorien mehr aber
ansonsten wenn jemand sagt okay ich mich
gern zum beispiel abends mal weg bringen
und anbieter zwar schnell gehen muss
dann sind schick ist ratz fatz gemacht
hat wenig kalorien und fett ist okay gut
zu wissen denn ich habe bisher noch
keinen getrunken aber hab schon viel
davon gehört
jetzt hast und das ist praktisch das
gleiche nur mit vanille ja okay dann
haben wir quark benutze ich auch hier
habe ich tatsächlich glaube ich noch
nicht benutzen das gesagt joghurt und
quark mittendrin joghurt ungefähr so 56
gramm eiweiß auf 100 gramm
das g hat ein bisschen mehr quark hat
noch am meisten ab und es ist einfach
auch ein bisschen fester als ein joghurt
deswegen dass er nicht ganz so flüssig
wetter kommen okay natürlich war noch
kurz ein lächeln muss man mehrfach
probieren oder dass man auch dann finden
sie darin käsekuchen also bitte hätte
ich zurück bisschen das ist schmeckt mir
tatsächlich besser als quark weil
magerquark an sich kann ich dass das rad
das schmeckt wie tapeten kleister was ja
im türkischen sagt man hasenhüttl das
macht mein mund so ja genau das habe ich
jetzt wo ich gehört habe aber gehört
dass ist nach den nutzer so mager sieht
den mund zusammen war gefragt als ich
mag ich auch nicht sehr gerne quatsch
ich vertrag auf milchprodukte mb produkt
hervorragend
ich liebe den 20 prozent frage immerhin
war der kläger sahnequark aber dass hier
hier drin gebe eben viele andere ok
zutaten und haben ein frischkäse doppel
rahmen ganz minimal ich mag auch
kalorienreduzierten frischkäse gar netz
und ich bin ich früh haben ist ein
frischkäse auf brot mit oliven und das
ist käse kuchen geschmack kopieren wie
kommt der käsekuchen geschmack rein
lasst mich kurz keinen käsekuchen aroma
85 minuten bis zum hafen und olive ist
ein ballaststoff und der ist super gut
für ein gesundes mikrobiologen das ist
schon nicht schlecht was sollte
die arme okay okay aber es gibt eben
auch dann diesen typischen geschmack das
ist natürlich etwas richtig gesundes
nämlich klose flow sei
das sind keine toten für leben die noch
das ist auch gut so denn alles scho
getrocknet ja genau das sind
ballaststoffe und die sind für ein
gesundes mikrobiologen aber dass berlin
richtig wertvoll
ich bin übrigens jeden morgen
flohsamenschalen ich starte den tag
immer mit einem großen glas wasser mit
floss haben schon muss man schnell
trinken weil wenn man stehen lässt jetzt
voll eklig dann kommt kann das nicht
mehr halten ja da kann man ja es geht
einfach auf und das rutscht langsam
durch den darm und gerade wer
beispielsweise unter verstopfung leidet
da kam ich hier im fußraum scheiben echt
ein kleines wunder termin also es macht
fest was nicht fest ist und es lockert
was zu festes ist genau und deswegen
gehörte auch hier in meinen gesunden
casecon okay und dann haben wir ja ganz
diana statt und es herrschte im prinzip
in deinem backbuch in dem koch und
backbuch drin
ok genau und das rezept heißt hier horst
2.0 und da ist eine geniale community
entstanden es gibt eine bianca die
regelmäßig sonntags immer wieder
sonntags eine rubrik schreibt ja ok
anschluss eine facebook gruppe und ihre
fettzellen ihren körper heißt horst das
ist der chef der fettzellen und so
entstand hoher seine fälle heißt wie
heißt also und der käsekuchen ist der
horst fettkiller cache das heißt der
macht den horst schwer zu schaffen und
2.0 ist einfach weil es gab schon ein
rezept das war schon gut aber wir haben
es noch mal verfahren hat im case kuchen
aroma mir noch ein paar tagen und so
entstand eben das ganze jetzt die letzte
frage bevor wir starten wir machen jetzt
diesen käsekuchen würdest du jetzt sagen
das ist ein gesunder käsekuchen oder
einfach gesündere variante
na ja die frage ist was ist gesund was
das ist es nicht weil ich will nie sagen
etwas ist gesund oder nicht gesund da
wird wahrscheinlich eher sagen
kilokalorien reduziert er hatte ihn
reich also gesund nicht gesund heißt 0 1
licht aus oder schlau und ja das ist
eben das nicht der fall also die ganzen
zutaten hier sieht man das sind alles
sehr vernünftige grundlage und deswegen
würde ich schon sagen das ist ein
gesunder gesünderer was aber nicht
bedeutet dass ihr diesen käsekuchen
jeden tag haben es mittags und abends
grund da muss ich sagen wenn man doch
immer die kalorien sehen weil er ein
stück käsekuchen hat also das ist schon
etwas was man jeden tag völlig bedenken
vielleicht sogar zusätzlich zum essen
ist ok weil es sind wirklich sehr sehr
wenige kalorien und eben viel eiweiß und
eiweiß setting etwas hat man so viele
andere so wichtige funktionen für hormon
stoffe beispielsweise zum ist nämlich
für die machen jetzt muss er nur noch
schmeckt weil oft sagt man ja was gesund
ist darf man von morgens bis abends
essen und ok aber jeden tag suchen wir
natürlich auch ein bisschen ja und
bewohnt ist kommt die süße herbekommt
die süße diese kommen vor
und das ist da noch drin das ist ein
rohstoff und zwei babys das leben einige
kenntnis der junge positiven ganz genau
6 uhr im garten
ok also proteine stevia und jetzt machen
wir den cup so das ist wir testen heute
das erste rezept auf diesen punkt legen
los
nämlich dass sie anfangen einfach mal
mit dem eher friedlichen land macht das
hier ein bisschen professioneller
deswegen machen wir nehmen da hatte ich
schon öfter gemacht
[Musik]
sollte der engel behilflich sein ich
gehe schon dankeschön und hier von 4
telefon käsekuchen
ganz easy alles egal wir ein zuerst er
flüssig dann eher das pulver und sogar
die flohsamen scheint zucker ist der
genaue zuckermann betonen kein zu können
so gar kein ich glaube du bist so
schnell wohl schon mal debatte bei mir
hat es vorhin vor lange gedauert aber
und wie viel grad ist halt ein schneller
wirst du kein wild an zu lesen wie viel
gras zeltes das sind 232 minuten auf der
unteren stufe um lobt das ist korrekt
200 kreislauf darum luft ja ich denke
auch dass ein bisschen wie ihnen machen
kann also das ist der verbrennt dollar
nach oben
so jetzt gibt es hier mal eine kleine
besonderheit wir haben hier keinen boden
drin ja lösung ich und das kurz und das
ist ja ziemlich flüssig ich weiß nicht
wie das ist weil ich habe damit keine
erfahrung es könnte theoretisch unten
raus laufen sei es schon etwas flüssiger
schlagen meine rolle nicht überzeugt
damit es wirklich stimmt wir haben
nichts zusätzlich reingemacht kann es im
springen über calvin schmeckt schon
längst das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht
ja das weiß denken viele nicht dass man
gesund kochen weil den spruch ich mir
gerade überlegt habe gut er kommen die
z1 ellis google ran aber er ist ganz
okay aber der ist schon ja da wird nicht
an den ich kenne ich bin keiner kenne
deswegen finde ich das schon
man muss es eigentlich mit so überfüllt
dass ich habe dennoch nicht gemacht und
dann machst du so also letztlich wieder
jetzt aber er schmeckt nach kinski
sollte ich habe schon in der
vergangenheit aber ich habe schon in der
vergangenheit schon mal so ein paar
gesunde dafür soll schon gegen die aus
katzen gerne das kannst du besser als
ich acht wir haben ja gar keinen boden
genau das werde jetzt den weg bringen
ein sympathisch warum aber ich finde sie
cool ich habe ihr gesagt wie sowieso
beim brand also ach so ja gleich ich
finde das innere besser wichtiger also
da kommt der bereich ja da kommt jetzt
in den backofen wenn jetzt mal die
backzeit geändert 170 grad ober
unterhitze haben jetzt mal gewählt so
dass leistungsfähige ja und dann glaube
ich auch danach 40 45 minuten fertiges
weil wir backen auch ohne boden das
heißt ich habe diese backform hat euch
das zu 20 prozent schnellere backzeit
auch okay was mit der optik muss man da
es in mittelstreu das verläuft sich
gleich also nochmal auch gerade für
meine kommen der boden hier unten
karcher und das verringert die backzeit
um 20 prozent das spart strom sparen und
kalorien sparen den ein und verkauf
[Musik]
hast du lust auf käsekuchen
wenn wir fertig sind das was überbleibt
käsekuchen oder ein nicht so gesunden
aber das war richtig lenkerin beide oder
machst du lieber papa oder mama ist so
gerne gesund
jetzt sehen wir was hast du heute morgen
im kindergarten gegessen was gab es
heute zum frühstücken ananas was noch
mit
das war dein board drauf dass ich nicht
das kriege ich leider nicht raus aus ihr
sie liebte leber post hatte ich heute
auch schon lieber nicht viel vitamin a
oder drin
okay lass dir zeit ja unser käsekuchen
ist im backofen beide werden
gleichzeitig fertig
ich würde sagen wir verbrennen die
kalorien die wir jetzt gleich zu uns
nehmen wollen
ich kenne keine verstünden laufen gehen
ja das geht mit kaffee kuchen essen dann
musst du ein paar purzelbäume machen und
das war's okay jetzt gehen wir rutschen
und sport machen und dann gibt es danach
gleich die käsekuchen vertröstung ich
freue mich mehr auf den käsekuchen
erzielten spuren nicht auch ja wir
müssen nicht gehen betonte aufhören ich
bin voll sport motiviert
da gehen wir zum sport geht es zunächst
zur kinderbetreuung kinderbetreuung im
rat geben wir darum ab dann verwechselte
[Musik]
com calvin verdiene dir dein kers kuchen
jetzt aber jetzt bei mir im
fitnessstudio ich bin auch wirklich zeit
ungefähr acht wochen echt konsequent und
kommt 23 sogar manchmal vier mal die
woche also vor hoch motiviert vor allem
sonntags comeback ende denn wir nehmen
die kinder einfach immer mit auch unter
der woche gibt es eine kinderbetreuung
und ich habe mir einfach einen sport
programm zusammenstellen lassen
das heißt am anfang erstmal bisschen
ausdauer will aufwärmen so wie jetzt und
meistens mich echt wohl so 15 minuten
auf dem crosstrainer aber in letzter
zeit nehme ich einfach mein handy mit
stellt hier ab und guck entweder
eigentlich meiner videos oder einfach
dass netflix oder auf youtube was
anderes und dann schaffe ich es meist
auch eine dreiviertelstunde
dann ist nämlich nicht nur aufwärmen
sondern auch bisschen ausdauer
[Musik]
also ich mach ja cross wird was wird da
gibt es verschiedene übungs
kombinationen und viele haben auch einen
namen
heute machen wir sind die cable hat
schon mal erlebt wir haben schon
passieren die gemacht das erste world
von uns wieder übungs erfolge
20 minuten lang so viele runden wie
möglich eine runde ist fünf klimmzüge
machst du nicht du machst dir tabs dafür
gab's also okay dann da kommen die zehn
mal liegestütz das kann ja auch sich auf
den knien
probier's mal auf den knien - gestützt
wir standen ja du bist jetzt an
ach so ja das habe ich gesehen wie die
gestern ja da kann es auch sie machen
aber es kann wie gestützt der drei
viertel liegestütze und drittens nie
beugen
das kannst du 15 stück also 15 15 5
setups im moment ist das wirklich so ja
dann hast du auch da machst du einfach
nicht um eine kniescheibe die sind so
aus ja das stimmt ja dann ist das
natürlich suboptimal
du könntest vielleicht ein bisschen
breiter stehen und dann gehst du einfach
nur so weit runter angst völlig in
ordnung ist gibt den hintern bisschen
mehr hinten auslassen geraden rücken
sowie das machen kannst das waren sich
minuten so viele runden du musst eben
noch zählen können also schießt ihm ist
komplett ab
wir machen original sin die das bedeutet
klimmzüge fünfter und eben zehn
liegestütze und 15 kniebeugen ich habe
heute aber nicht ein da du siehst
insgesamt ziemlich kaputt aus aber du
kriegst es klappen meint geräte sport.ch
heute meine ausnahmen danach als ein
käsekuchen wirklich verstanden haben und
vielleicht kurz noch die agents und ich
mache ganz verrückte klimmzügen muss man
sich nach machen brauchen ein techniker
für das muss man können sonst könnte es
schädlich sein ja also nicht wundern
wenn man das sieht was da heißt für
blödsinn macht aber das ist eben fonds
fit und kein
gewöhnlicher aber so sport mit dem
eigenen gewicht ist schon anstrengend ja
auf alles werde mein gewicht nicht
tragen
denn jetzt sei das des spaghetti aber
[Musik]
zwei habe ich schon nicht übertreiben
auf anfrage sagte liegestütze des setups
unterstützen zusammengestutzt da macht
doch irgendwo kannst doch ein kissen
drunter macht irgendwas dass du nicht
ganz so weit runter muss echt spaghetti
aber ich kann mich da nicht ein einziges
kann dass keine frau recht natürlich
wird das ist nicht das hatten wir schon
mal jemand sagen kann aber aber fünf
zeugen schon vom eines angriffs mit
kritik doch ich kann dafür backen 5
[Musik]
bis 8
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
auch nicht so lang sagen herr hollywood
etwas schneller bieten
[Musik]
meine
so mache ich mir dieser kannte das
spürst du auch dann hier wie dem tier
zusammen fürst ja das ist eine sehr
brauchen aber auch gar nicht viel machen
also dürften weit nach vorn genau und
dann gehst du einfach hier unter
appartements erleben also nicht nach
vorne geht es in der ersten vergehen
wieder hoch und runter genau das kann es
auch mal mit festhalten damit der stadt
liegt
auf die andere seite
[Musik]
ich schaffe nicht nur die kalorien ich
habe einfach zu viel
ich warte will ja bodychecks gekentert
[Musik]
versteht mich
ja ich bin auch gleichzeitig noch ein
stück dann kann ich das ganze grundstück
kaufen
[Musik]
so macht jetzt bei sport da kommen die
oberarme
[Musik]
aber wenn das der murat ihr seht der
kommt nicht mehr ins fitnessstudio
vorbei doch er kommt an jeden tag aber
den tischkicker nicht mehr zum piesberg
so ungeschlagen
[Musik]
die jungs da kommt man gar nicht durch
hh
der käsekuchen vergleich also eins muss
man dazu sagen der morales war dafür
zuständig den keks kuchen aus dem ofen
zu holen
leider hat es nicht geschafft die
richtige backzeit abzuwarten
bei dem jahre bei der strand so
eingefallen also darauf bissle was
falsch gemacht na ja aber da hat der
kuchen ja da hat der kuchen so schnell
geht wenn ich den gleichen backen und
fairerweise dann richtig packen und dann
fotografiere ich den schöneren okay gut
es lag nicht an uns lag am ok kalorien
vergleich wie viel hast deinen ganzen
kuchen etwas mehr als 1500 kalorien
unserer hat etwa 7000 kalorien aber man
muss dazu sagen wir haben 27 kilogramm
masse
naja ich bin schon sagen der ist
wahrscheinlich doppelt so schwer
aber trotzdem noch mit den kalorien
natürlich natürlich insgesamt sind ich
schätze ich mal etwas weniger als die
hälfte am tag
und wenn man auch hier zwölf stück
gerechnet hat jedes stück ungefähr 600
kalorien und jäger stück ungefähr 100
kalorien ist auch ein bisschen kleiner
da es ja ganz gut 200 kalorien
okay man müsse jetzt auf 100 km rechnen
dann wird nur 100 gramm werde jetzt bei
ihm ihr 260 kalorien
das geht doch mein gott ok sommer
fairerweise so starten also ich will so
sein tipp den design award ist der hier
ganz klar naja da sieht es noch so ein
bisschen aus wie so eine aufgeblähte
pizza sage ich mal
also design award gesunder liga eins zu
eins ist kommt sie auf den geschmack
haben im prinzip an ein fairer weise
probier es den 2
in sachen geschmack ganz knapp der
gewinn aber nur soweit ich weiß selbst
nicht so süß deswegen musste kurz
betroffenen nicht erst mit dem
hintergrund dass er gesund ist aber ich
finde das ist aber dass ich bekomme ich
mir ist so habe ich geb dir ein stück
eisen der stadt allerdings hat zwei
stunden von mixa das kissen als ab
diesem moment ist alles gut wie lange
wartest du darauf schon erzählt also auf
denen er ist schon bei dem indie
überrascht als wir mal gespannt hier
lass dich überraschen aber er riecht
mega leckere kuchen hier müsste ich das
risiko ich muss mal also für ein
wirklich gesunden käsekuchen ist dass
ich meine dass ich eine coole
alternative überraschend überrascht mich
gerade so ist das wird nicht überrascht
doch sehr dass ich jetzt nicht gedacht
dass das so gut schmeckt der schmeckt
das schmeckt nicht so ganz cremig aber
ich finde denn von der süße hat perfekt
weil ich mag es ähnlich so gerne sowie
raps und man hätte hier auch nochmal
drehen drauf machen können richtig oder
genau das ist auch wahrscheinlich
deswegen gerissen oben wegen dieser
oberflächenspannung wenn du noch so
behrendt drauf macht dann passiert ist
habe ich gelernt durch durch das wusste
ich auch nicht aber der calvin hat nur
links gesagt also das schmeckt wie käse
kuchen
es sind ja zur ausblick ist also anders
aus aber das land ja schlecht sagen und
ich sind auch also wenn das stück jetzt
wirklich 100 kalorien hat er locker zwei
stück essen die hormone probleme sogar
nach dem essen
er war nach dem sport man könnte jetzt
so ein bisschen experimentieren damit
mit mit der wird kann man nicht noch so
eine kombi machen dass man sagt da wir
uns auch gar nicht so gesund zeichnet
diese europäer 200 kalorien hat dass man
ein bisschen zu können es ist dieses
back weiß macht man normalerweise in
gewöhnliche rezept macht eine halbe also
wir haben jetzt hier 25 nur 25 km von
der backe habt könnt ihr eure wunderbar
für sie haben doch ganz normales weizen
leben völlig egal ob's medien 405 ist
oder eben eins mit doch ein bisschen
mehr mineraliengehalt ich denke mal das
wird noch ein bisschen anders schmecken
soll gas werden auch überrascht weil ich
habe den kuchen ja auch zuhause probiert
ich habe nicht ganz legalen bekommen
warum weiß ich nicht ich kann es einfach
nicht so gut button betroffen
schmeckt auch flüssig finde ich von der
konsistenz hier
und wenn wir jetzt den geschmack haben
das aussehen und was aber noch bunte
sachen gesundheit dann würde ich sagen
dann gewinnt er aber wir dürfen eines
nicht vergessen die zubereitungszeit und
da ist der minuten fünf minuten alles
was nicht
ja und dann könnte es sein das ist nun
entschieden wird
einfach jeder moment diesem moment er
hat vier lange drauf gewartet
immer wenn ein live video macht und ich
sehe ist ein crash ich so das live-video
schreiben über käse kuchen käse kommt
can score entwischen und unkonzentriert
noch konsterniert aber nachts auch
dritten käsekuchen ist noch warm
guck mal der hat richtig geschmacks
verständlich
endlich geschafft
als entschuldigung
das müssen sie mit rogan ich war sogar
engels gehöre ich würde jetzt gern mein
gesicht nehmen
jetzt müsst ihr nur noch eiskalt sein
jetzt noch kalt das zweite stück ich mir
gleich nach dem einholen des kalte stück
max kanister quartal gibt kaltes stück
das schmeckt selbstverständlich
sensationell
aber jetzt mal ganz ehrlich ist der
geschmack zu den gesunden her dramatisch
unterschiedlich also da schmeckt
remigianer der chemiker prof
doch um diesen verfüge als das hier aber
von der süße helfen dies gar nicht so
unterschiedlich die süße aber wenig
macht es schon ja kann ich nämlich
musste später rede ich jetzt halt wenn
da noch so hart ist aggressiv zuvor zum
abreißen so auch noch fast alles ist
ruhig sein
das geht also voran ist hier erkennt das
einfach so ist ein fester die konsistenz
und desto weniger aber ich finde es
nicht schlimm da sollte ich daran die
noch nicht gemacht also fast so hat es
auch 35 minuten gedauert
also ich fand den käsekuchen vergleich
jetzt wirklich super ich würde mir
wünschen wir könnten das öfter so person
klassisch versus gesünder wäre wohl ja
ihr könnt ihr mal in die kommentare
schreiben und kelvin wird unser
professioneller produkt da costa und
zwischendurch war immer so ein schönes
hartes workout gerade richtig neidisch
sportart balance zum spaß hätte ich auch
gerne messen
sie sind unterschiede aber durch den
schwedischen über zurück als stehen voll
gegessen ist meine geschmacksnerven sind
völlig zerstört deswegen erst denkt
werden noch mal wirklich süßes isst und
was wir sind weil der war ich sehr gut
kenne so aber jetzt stehen habe muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen scheiterte 600
kalorien sowie profis mit kann man
könnte ich zwei essen davon
[Musik]
dafür kündigt im ganzen essen und davon
halten
er oder ich könnte jetzt komplett weg
schließlich könnte ich können jetzt
komplett weghauen löst will ich weiß wie
ich mich dann heute abend viel aber ich
könnte den komplett weg also ich hoffe
es hat auch spaß
dann schreibt sie die kommentare sie
auch spaß gemacht hab da mal weil das
gerne öfter ja gesund und lecker
natürlich darfst du ja ich nehme auch
von dem noch mal also die rezepte gibt
es natürlich in meiner app und auf dem
blog alles zum nachrichten probiert den
ausprobieren aber unbedingt auch mal aus
also wirklich das schmeckt wirklich
super super lecker nicht zum web 2.0 und
wie viel zu den nennen an torsten albig
vielleicht gut und über hast du noch was
von meinem hof bögel
jetzt lassen wir mal ganz kurz alleine
darauf dass die heldin und seinen kuchen
ich würde es dann noch das lustige video
bevor ich nicht mehr ist in keiner weise
etwas mit essen zu tun okay was gewiss
bei uns und hat was mit essen zu tun
wenn ich werde dem essen so dass
natürlich auch toll wenn diese tipps
kommen die hat dass man wäre der zähne
putzen kniebeugen machen soll mir macht
das so ich mache mal den übungen spastik
kopf weil das gerade geräuschkulisse in
den betrieben kein kurs ist das ist
dieses jahr und lassen was ich gerade
die vorstellung aber das ist eben gesagt
nachdem abtreibungen stadt den übungen
[Musik]